we had a tweet recently suggesting we do
a video on
aloha net which i think we've had brief
discussions about before but it's some
really
early form of kind of um network is it
was it something to do with hawaii i
mean you know you're the hawaiian shirt
guy
yeah so um yeah no aloha is probably the
sort of
grandfather of pretty much all networks
that we use today i think it was 68 the
norman abramson
started to work on this technology along
with others and the technology that was
used has
influenced ethernet it's influenced gprs
satellite communication is still in use
today in various forms
so it was based in hawaii he was at the
university of hawaii and they had a big
expensive ibm mainframe that they wanted
to
provide access to but because hawaii is
a series of islands
they couldn't just run cables everywhere
and so they decided that they would
build a wireless network
in 1968
this wasn't off-the-shelf equipment
right yeah they had to develop this all
themselves you couldn't just go and buy
a cisco
wi-fi access point and stick it up on
top of a tower because cisco hadn't been
created yet that was still
12 years in the future if not more 15
years in the future
and of course cisco only existed because
of the technology that was developed as
part of aloha
so they were literally developing all
this from themselves
and so what they had is that they had
two radio frequencies that they'd use
they used one to
transmit from the ibm computer out
across all the islands of hawaii and
then they had another
radio frequency that they used to
transmit back from all the terminals
that people were using
back to the central computer now they
had a sort of a simple situation because
they had a very definite model that they
had
one computer the ibm mainframe it was at
this point they had data going from the
ibm mainframe
to all of the other machines and they
were receiving data from many machines
transmission was a one-to-many problem
and that's great because you then only
have one computer that's sending
anything
so that computer can break its data down
into packets which is what they did
and then sequence them so they get sent
out and there's no sort of corruption
as that data is transmitted actually
what they did was that they had another
computer that sat in front of the ibm
mainframe they had a
hp computer they bought an hp mini
computer and they dedicated that to
doing all this processing and splitting
data into packets reassembling it
passing the data back on to the ibm
mainframe they refer to this
hp computer as the menu hewn and i
apologize if i've mispronounced that
name
which is a hawaiian word for elf they
sort of
played on the word elf because it was
based on some of the ideas that were
being developed as part of the arpanet
for the interface message processor so
they were sort of imp
elf you can see how the sort of train of
thought moves along so they have this
secondary computer the menu that was
sitting between the ibm and everything
else
so it got data from the ibm and could
then transmit it out as packets
to all the terminals wherever they are
over the radio frequency
in a serial fashion modulating it deep
as it needed to be
and they just transmitted it out so
sending data from the ibm
to the terminals was fine the terminals
could then receive the packets see if it
was for them if it wasn't displayed on
screen if it wasn't
you just ignore it and so on they didn't
worry about security in those days i'm
sure it was just clear text and
receive it but they had much more of a
problem getting data back so when you
type something into the computer
you need to send that data back to the
ibm mainframe so that you can deal with
things
and so what they realize what the sort
of key contribution that norman abrams
and and the others who are working on
this
sort of realized was how can we send
that data back to the ibm computer via
the menu
in as simple a way as possible and the
problem you've got is that
you've got several computers dotted all
around the islands
and it's potentially possible that two
of them might transmit at the same time
and if two of them were to transmit at
the same time it's the same as two
people speaking at the same time
they would interfere with each other and
the computer at the other end wouldn't
be able to receive the signal
and so they would corrupt each other's
messages so they were trying to make
sure that
any computer could transmit at any point
but that you didn't have corruption of
the messages as they were sent
what they realized was that they didn't
need the data to be
received correctly necessarily the first
time they received it
that it would actually be okay if it
could be eventually received that
you might transmit it and it wouldn't
get received so then you'd have to
transmit it again
and so what they realize if you relax
things and say okay
we want eventual packet delivery as it's
called we want to be able to receive it
at some point
you can actually start to say well okay
we can transmit at any point
to make best use of the bandwidth i mean
you could use say time division
multiplexing where you break your
channel your radio channel up into
segments that are some percentage of a
second long
and you say okay this computer can only
transmit in that point of time
and then this computer can only transmit
at this point of time but if you do that
you find that you're not actually using
the bandwidth that well because most of
the time particularly on something like
a terminal
people are typing and they'll type
something then they'll read the response
and then they'll type something else
actually that doesn't use the bandwidth
you've got available that effectively
what they realized was they could make
best use of the bandwidth by just saying
okay
you can send the packet whenever you
like so any of the terminals if they had
some data to be sent you type something
into the keyboard
it would then just attempt to send that
data to
the ibm via the menu so it's modulated
into the radio signal
send it out over the radio transmitter
it'd be received by the menu
and then it'd be sort of decoded and
passed to the
ibm computer to do whatever it was you
wanted it to do
and if you were the only thing
transmitting that would be absolutely
great
you could send the data out and it would
be received
but what happens if there's two of you
transmitting at the same time so you're
typing on your computer i'm typing on
mine
and we send the data at the same time
well of course the data is received
by the menu is a mix of the two messages
so it won't make any sense it'll be
corrupted
but they realize that this was okay
because what they got the computer to do
is that when you receive the data
correctly it sent out another bit of
data back to the machine that sent it
saying
i've received what you sent correctly so
you would send your data from your
terminal
it would get sent up and the menu you
would receive and you would send a
message back saying
yep got that acknowledge and then you'd
know it'd been received
and what they realized was if you just
send it out
and you don't get that response
that means the menu didn't receive it
and if the many who didn't receive it
you just send it again
and then hopefully that time he gets
through and then you get the acknowledge
response and if you don't you send it
again until
you get the acknowledged response and
your terminal does exactly the same
thing it gets the
doesn't get an acknowledged response so
waits a certain amount of time
and the key thing is you need some sort
of algorithm in place to sort of decide
who sends after what sort of time if
everyone just waited the same amount of
time you'd get the same sort of problem
and things and so it just waited for a
short amount of time
pick it randomly use it based on the
station id various approaches they could
use i can't remember exactly which one
they used in the low car
it doesn't matter and then you resend
your data and eventually it will get
through
and what they found was that this
actually provided really good use of the
bandwidth most people could transmit
when they wanted to
but could also detect packet collisions
when two people tried to transmit at the
same time
and recover from them by resending the
packets now it meant that the terminals
had to have a little bit of intelligence
to them to be able to sort of
keep track of the packets and check
whether it'd been received or not but
you could implement that relatively
straightforwardly and so
it produced a system that could work and
this was operational by about 1971
and used all over hawaii and then as
they were developing it they did some
sort of later
improvements one thing they realized is
that if you just allow people to send at
any point
then you could have a packet collision
which could destroy two packets
if only a single bit collided in between
them both packets would be destroyed
um you wouldn't receive them correctly
that's a better way of putting that and
so you'd have to resend them
so what they actually did in a slightly
later variation of it which is known as
slotted aloha
is that they said okay you can transmit
at any time
but you must align it to certain time
points and so you have all the machines
synchronized
and so you can either transmit say that
0 seconds or 0.001 second or 0.002
second for example
and if you do that you then either get a
packet collision
where the whole packets collide because
they're transmitted at the same time or
you don't get a packet collision because
if someone starts transmitting something
and someone else wants to transmit
say about halfway through it it has to
wait until the next transmission point
to which to do it at which point they
won't collide
whereas if you can say transmit at any
point then you can sort of start
transmitting and then i start
transmitting
and it destroys them and that could just
sink that could just be as simple as a
single bits get corrupted at the end
at which point you've destroyed the
whole transmission of two packets when
if you'd waited one bit neither packet
would have been destroyed so that was
the sort of improvement that they
developed
now i said that aloha net was sort of
the grandfather the granddaddy of all
the sort of different networks
and that's because when people were
developing things like ethernet and
xerox park in the sort of mid-70s
they'd heard of the work it been
published and they'd heard of the word
that norman abrams and his team
had done in hawaii and they sort of took
the same ideas
so ethernet for example run originally
ran on a single piece of wire that
stretched around the office
and the machines were literally
physically clamped onto the ethernet
cable
so they but they still use the same
ideas they still said okay anyone can
transmit at any point
um if the data doesn't get received then
we'll retransmit things
but because they were on a physical
piece of wire they could do some extra
things to sort of
for example they could see whether
someone was already transmitting
and so they could sort of say okay
someone's already transmitting i'll wait
until they've finished so they could
sort of get better performance
but they were sort of very much aware of
the work that norman and his team have
done
and we're building on top of that and
that's followed through into things like
gprs
satellite communications they're all
still using this sort of idea
you still get straight aloha networks
out there i think laura wan
the sort of iot things at times can work
in that sort of a
fashion that you just literally send
things out wait for acknowledgement if
you don't get that acknowledgement
then you send it out again after a
certain amount of time until the data is
eventually
received so yeah really great piece of
work it provided wireless networking for
the hawaii community
of the hawaii academic community of
computer scientists let's limit this to
the people who are actually using it
probably
way back in the 60s 70s and yeah has
really influenced the way that sort of
networking technology has been developed
diagram i'm drawing very badly here and
so on so you'd have two sets of pulses
one delayed from the other it's what we
call quadrature encoding
we can actually derive from that which
direction the signal is moving in
so yeah they're very different to the
originals and the important thing is
that
we don't know what went into here